ciò continua allora questo video nasce
dalla voglia spasmodica di seguire un
trend che recentemente è stato legato su
youtube che collide la blind fool
challenger praticamente due youtube e
cosa fanno si sfidano e uno ben
dall'altro e li sottopone delle cose del
dominare senza la possibilità di
utilizzare la vista la persona che è
stata scelta per permetter nella prova è
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ceneri è sempre un cantante dei daft
punk pop punk che l'italia la sfida
eppure quella di comprimere il cervello
con la mano il motore sarà quella
ragazzi ho paura io poi avere manie la
merda no è una e dov'è nata allora
iniziamo con allora tu sei fisse in due
a farmi un pugno da un pugno 0
vuoi essere gentili sono stato
gentilissimo con questo primo uomo si è
così ma io ho visto gli opuscoli gli
ospiti intero ma perché c'è qualcuno
modalità nadia portiere in dominato da
questo l'ho preso perché un nome
spettacolare come se fossi io
petra kliba cos'è asta corsa a due ditte
che se fagioli si fa sole cook ospitate
a casa questo mi piaceva allora se non
metti la mano come se volessi un euro
tipo cose da spalmare di mare si
bravissima nuova donna
l'ho preso perchè magari complicato
pensata corsa mi diceva bene
bravissimo forse tutto nel finale mio
preferito
sembra che fa 20 il dito indice e io ora
ti inviterò con la mia voce
vieni più avanti e avanti così dire più
avanti più avanti beh insomma più sobri
tito una persona va mai sempre di più
mai mai mai una decisione di tale data
sentivo qualcosa più figo dammi il
titolo daniela po più invece si
prospetta definita o sei su sei
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma la mia buio il pù nello hobbit
bottino gianni bugno e il dalle mie
parti questione